hello guys Greg Alba over here I'm
pretty sick right now I got a lot of
symptoms and that's why this video is
coming Ali I feel a little decent right
now so I'm like alright now is the time
to film this rogue one a Star Wars story
the immediate prequel to Episode four
directed by gareth edwards who did
godzilla
and monsters so i already sold on that I
know Donnie ends in it I love the hitman
movies or the Ip Man and I still don't
know if I strong it matter Ip Man state
your name for the record
gen also forgery of Imperial documents
from stolen property aggravated assault
it was this thing arrest it's just like
hidden on your own from the age of fifty
reckless aggressive and undisciplined
this is a rebellion isn't it I still
have the old sound effects IRA Belle
the solution for you
the major weapons test is imminent we
need to know what it is
how to destroy it is that clear yes you
do wouldn't it catch you
when you do agree
if you continue to fight
what will you
I think it looks awesome man I think it
looks really cool yeah I'm sure there's
gonna be some crap this film's gonna get
like I didn't realize that Felicity
Jones was the star of this movie like
the main lead
I guess Star Wars is into this thing
round where they cast young British
female Heath oh boy well feeling that
sickness coming back I thought the
trailer relieved it whew
no but some obvious things that I really
like from it the tone I think is really
cool if this movie has a similar dark
tone it's like there's a lot of Star
Wars nostalgia in there but I like them
to take in a more dark realistic
approach
I don't know realistic surround word but
it's a darker approach for sure now in
this Canon of Star Wars movies is it a
film that's no eating the franchise I
don't know I can't tell yet if it's
truly unnecessary prequel regardless
though it looks just cool to step back
into the Star Wars world of the 70s
although you know like one weird thing
that I got what and this is not a big
bother for me it does kind of feel like
a young adult novel in a way cuz you got
this young woman rebellious and she has
to lead the rebellion you knows there's
some Hunger Games touches to there for
sure I feel like some people will
automatically have a problem with that
because already oh my god of course
you're gonna clean your leaves at this
hour cuz I know people when I hear the
word young adult they already like start
getting mad cuz they hate the whole
concept that when a young adult novel is
there are some definite similarities
here although this looks like it could
be one of the better versions of a young
woman being rebellious she's British
again you know like we already got that
with Ray it's a problem they're both
very good-looking woman I would gladly
watch them on screen because of how hot
they are and the fact that they're tough
meaning BDSM possibly and I'm just
really excited to see Donnie Yen in this
trailer you know I'm glad they showed
him in the trailer because a lot of
people love the hitman movies like I
said don't know if it's Ip Man or it man
but in the movies that sound like they
were seeing it man but you know they
show funny with a bow finding those
stormtroopers um I had a joke
maybe he asks
to fight 10 stormtroopers just a little
Easter egg joke for you
I think Forrest Whitaker is really cool
I don't know how people are gonna feel
about Forest Whitaker being in Star Wars
movies I don't know why I said it like
they might have a problem but Forrest
Whitaker is a great [ __ ] actor and
it's cool to see it Academy Award
winning actor in this [ __ ] film I I
don't know if he's playing the villain
or not date either way because I know
Darth Vader is supposed to be in here
and a lot of people want the Darth Vader
from the rogue squadron stories you know
I like the way he moves in the video
game like where he's just so [ __ ]
fast and it's like a terrifying force
force but I just love how everything it
looks like little legit Star Wars you
know the stormtroopers have those
helmets the ships the uniforms one thing
I'm hoping for those stormtroopers have
a pretty strong reputation for missing
their shots a lot and if this is like
the road team versus the stormtroopers
I'm really hoping the stormtroopers are
better at shooting in this movie not
saying it's exactly that plot I'm just
saying that when the stormtroopers are
there I would like for them to improve
on that and I know Darth Vader's in it
but remembering where episode four
started off with a story of the Jedi's I
don't imagine we'll get Jedi's in this
film excluding the Sith you know Darth
Vader the red lightsaber might be the
only lightsaber we see in this film but
regardless it looks [ __ ] cool I like
the tone I love the director everything
from what I'm seeing just looks like a
really interesting picture it really
feels like they're challenging
themselves to do something different ah
that's it okay now I know we haven't
seen VAE door just yet but at 1 minute
and 12 seconds it looks like that could
possibly be Darth Vader rocking his
[ __ ] ass robe that's my theory anyway
guys thanks for tuning to the channel
trailer made me feel a little bit better
if you're new to this channel subscribe
today become a reject and follow us on
our social networks like Facebook
Instagram Twitter and I'm gonna go throw
up now thank you